I'm really happy yes it's not over yet
let them bite at the end of it okay it's
nice that Russia made the right decision
I'm the odds okay I thinks you have a
message for your parents in the unit
yeah I love them and I looking forward
to speaking to them soon what is this
been like for you been the hardest
experience of my life I knew it when
your mind yup ugliest usko and I'm like
for you awful a real really stressful
time for me and more than anything I've
just been so worried about my family and
not being able to speak to anyone at
home and all for doing my job
essentially it's totally ridiculous and
I'm looking forward to getting the call
as soon as possible and explaining why
I'm not guilty of hooliganism or any
other crime you and there's a cameraman
absolutely I was there as a reporter as
I have been for the last six years of my
life so totally ridiculous missions be
like screaming first of all go for a
good meal I have some proper food and
have a beer and hopefully see my family
they're supposed to be coming over to
visit and see my girlfriend it'll be a
good time I hope and obviously there's a
lot to do and I've got some brilliant
lawyers helping me so yeah step in the
right direction the first smile I've had
for a while